on en fabrique chaque année 2,3
milliards à travers la planète et
certains d'entre eux parcourent parfois
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
kilomètres avant d'arriver sur les
étagères du magasin de prêt-à-porter je
vous propose donc de suivre l'utile
l'itinéraire d'un de ses jeans l'un des
itinéraires les plus longs alors notre
histoire ou plutôt notre voyage va
commencer en inde
alou diarra pourquoi dans ce pays et
bien tout simplement parce que pour
faire un jean
il faut du coton et que l'inde est le
premier producteur mondial de coton avec
6 millions trois cent cinquante mille
tonnes par an au passage je rappelle
mais vous l'avez dit que le coton
consomme beaucoup d'eau pour faire
pousser le coton nécessaires à la
fabrication d'un jeans il faut quatre
mille litres d'eau puis ce coton est
envoyé chez le voisin au pakistan à
karachi pour être filet et tisser étape
suivante la chine 4800 km plus à l'est
chine tang la capitale du jeans 3000
usines qui vont produire tenez vous bien
la toile nécessaires à la fabrication de
800000 jean par jour
voilà c'est là que la toile d'apprendre
de la couleur et les teintes en bleu
indigo alors pour cela les fabricants
utilisent un pigment de synthèse pour
fabriquer un kilogramme de ce pigment de
synthèse il faut une centaine de kg de
pétrole des solvants et 1000 litres
d'eau la toile est ensuite envoyé en
tunisie est encore 9500 km de plus au
compteur là elle est assemblée on va
ajouter vous savez les petits river qui
en général arrive d'australie la
fermeture éclair c'est devenu une
spécialité du japon quant au bouton et
bien très souvent il arrive de
république
mocratique du congo vous pensez que se
terminer et bien non pas encore le jean
va maintenant être délavé et envoyé au
bangladesh ou en égypte bangladesh la le
kilométrage est encore plus important à
dacca l'opération consiste à sable et le
jean
c'est une opération très nocive il
existe un système un peu plus vers ceux
qui utilisent le laser mais ça c'est
beaucoup plus cher voilà là le jean est
terminée ne reste plus qu à l'acheminer
vers la boutique où il sera vendu au
moment où ce jean va arriver sur les
étagères il aura consommé environ 11
milles litres d'eau et parcouru 65 mille
kilomètres l'équivalent d'une fois et
demie le tour de la terre et dire que
cette toile a un peu été inventé à nîmes
dans le sud de la france
benghazi 2e ville
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]